this is a code virus and this is the flu
the two have some similarities both are
respiratory diseases both mutate
regularly and both have vaccines that
can prevent serious illness and the
framework for updating the covet vaccine
might look similar to the one used for
the flu vaccine in the future we likely
are moving towards a path with a
vaccination Cadence similar to that of
the annual influenza vaccine but there
are some key differences between the
viruses and the vaccines the experts say
makes applying the same framework
challenging and those challenges have
created a debate on whether vaccinating
covid like we vaccinate the flu is
actually the best way to tackle the
virus
here's how the update process for the
flu vaccine works the flu is the only
vaccine that the CDC recommends to be
taken annually across the public even if
you've been naturally affected or
vaccinated the year before you may well
not be protected against serious illness
from the new strains that then come into
the country so that's why we need a
yearly through vest Dr Paul offit is a
member of the FDA committee that advises
the administration on which vaccines to
approve and to authorize for emergency
use influenza is a single stranded RNA
virus when single strain and RNA viruses
reproduce themselves they're not
terribly faithful for that reason then
as that genome is reproduced and
reproduced and reproduced there are
errors that can be incorporated annual
flu vaccines are typically trivalent or
quadrivalent meaning they cover three or
four different strains of the virus that
can be circulating at one time Global
health organizations and researchers
work together twice a year to decide
which strain should be included in the
vaccine
since the northern and southern
hemispheres have different flu Seasons
they look at which strains are already
circulating in other countries to
predict which ones might make their way
to the other side of the globe
updated flu vaccines don't typically go
through human trials for efficacy or
safety before they are distributed to
the public instead they rely on tests on
human samples like mucus and blood
animal testing and extensive experience
with the disease and vaccines
we have now decades worth of
correlations between
to give this vaccine it introduces a
certain immune response in mice or
ferrets that we can take a pretty good
guess as to whether or not it's going to
be effective based on what's circulating
and there are similarities between that
process and the process for the new
bivalent covid vaccines which were
authorized by the FDA in August these
new vaccines were cleared for use
without being tested in humans or having
the results from the human testing also
they target more than one strain but
there are also some differences because
kovid is less predictable than the flu
flu season typically runs from October
to march in the U.S that's when activity
Peaks
but while covid has had the strongest
surges in Winter there isn't a
predictable pattern yet for when the
spikes will start or when a new variant
might appear
flu vaccines have also been produced for
a long time and use a standardized
process to Target the same strains
coveted vaccines don't have the same
coordination mapped out yet with covid
we've got lots of companies working on
different Technologies of vaccines and
they are testing their vaccines with
different strains you know it's it's
sort of just um you know a little murky
or a little messy there as to what the
industry is doing the unpredictability
of the virus has made it tricky to know
when the right time to boost is
an FDA spokesperson said they don't know
yet if individuals will need to receive
additional booster doses of the covid-19
vaccine but it may be possible the
annual ones will be needed
there's a lot of variables that are sort
of unknown right now one is that the how
long the protection from these vaccines
will last is one thing that's still
being studied with the original coveted
vaccines some studies show that
neutralizing antibodies which help
prevent viruses from infecting cells may
start to wane after six months or even
sooner with newer variants but vaccines
also induce T cells which attack cells
infected by the virus when antibodies
fail some studies show that these cells
might offer longer protection even after
antibodies weighing
some experts think annual shots are the
best way to balance timing others aren't
convinced yet
there are experts there are doctors out
there who say hold on maybe we need to
do it more frequently maybe we need to
have a new vaccine every time we see a
sort of a worrisome variant we have some
who are saying one booster shot will
last you for several years maybe just
the first booster will be enough for
some people some like Dr offit also say
that while it's not clear if the entire
population would benefit from updated
boosters there's a clear benefit to some
this booster dosing frankly for for
those who are at highest risk is really
about the elderly people who are uh who
compromised people who have long-term
heart or belong
neurological disease but I don't think
there's there's a downside to taking it
I just don't think the upside is quite
what it's made out today
Offutt was in a minority that voted
against including an Omicron component
to updated boosters in June he says he
would have liked to see more data on the
vaccine and how it was administered I
didn't think data were presented that
we're convincing that the bivalent
vaccine was any better than the the
current vaccine but other experts say
that updated boosters will be a useful
tool in fighting the virus moving
forward modeling projections show that
an uptake of updated covid-19 vaccine
doses similar to an annual flu vaccine
coverage early this fall could prevent
as many as 100
000 hospitalizations 9
000 deaths and save billions of dollars
in direct medical costs medical experts
will be watching the rollout of the new
bivalent vaccines closely to make
decisions about the future vaccination
process
researchers will test these new bivalent
vaccines against these new variants and
they'll see how how well they work if
they if they work and that will sort of
set the course for changing vaccines in
the future
the White House said that we are moving
toward a point where an annual shot
should provide a large majority of
Americans protection all year barring
any major changes in the virus that
would warrant an update sooner